that was a dream now that dream became a
reality in 2003 where I played my first
game for the old blacks and I thought
that I could die the next day and die a
happy man because I've achieved
everything I dreamed of of achieving
today on Deep dive it's very exciting
because I am joined by the legendary Dan
Carter who is one of the greatest rugby
players of all time and Dan is super
famous all around the world but
especially in his home country of New
Zealand where he played for the All
Blacks for over 15 years every morning I
got out of bed I wanted to be the best
rugby player I Poss speak could that's
what was driving my decision making uh
almost each and every day now danad
knows all about performing Under
Pressure but he's also encountered
significant setbacks in his career and
since his retirement from the
professional game he's gone on to become
a leader and an adviser and also a
writer we talk about how to overcome
setbacks we talk about how to figure out
what your purpose is and we talk about
how to perform well under pressure and
become a lifelong winner of which a big
part is defining success for yourself
the most successful people in the world
live with pressure every day so actually
it's not what a burden to have pressure
in your life it's a privilege all those
thoughts of why me why now why such a
serious injury nothing made sense in my
mind at all everything had just been
taken away from me halfway on the
Journey Back to the Hotel I hey Doc you
know as my world cup dream over and
she's like yes and I just burst into
tears I cried all the way back to the
hotel but then you know after a couple
of days I was like well hold on like you
know what does an all black great do in
situations like this so my purpose
really helped me through uh through this
the
setback right so recently I've started
to think a lot about my health and
that's why I'm very excited to say that
this episode is brought to you by hu now
I've been using he since 2017 since my
5ifth year of medical school but since
interviewing the founder Julian Hearn on
this podcast in season 1 and hearing the
origin story of heel and how it came
together hu has now become a staple part
of my life now if you haven't heard of
it hu is essentially a meal in a bottle
so each little bottle is like a shake
that has 400 calories 22 g of protein
and a good balance of carbs and fats and
fiber along with 26 different vitamins
and minerals and obviously when it comes
comes to health there is nothing that
beats the gold standard which is a
healthy nutritional freshly prepared
meal that has like the perfect balance
of all the things but if you lead a
particularly busy or hectic lifestyle
like I sometimes do it can be hard to
make the time in our schedules to get
this absolute gold standard Meal which
is why I personally like using hu for
those moments of my day or of my life
where I don't quite have time to cook I
don't quite have time to like try and go
to like a gourmet restaurant and S of
get some kind of healthy meal I just
want something that covers my bases in
terms of the macros that I need and
that's pretty tasty as well the heel
ready to drink bottles come in eight
different flavors my favorite ones are
banana and salted caramel so if you find
those you should check those out and if
you're interested in trying these out
then head over to heal.com deepdive and
with your first order you'll also get a
free Shaker if you want the heel
powdered version and you'll also get a
free t-shirt these are quite nice
T-shirts they fit very well they make
the biceps look a lot bigger so thank
you so much heal for sponsoring this
episode this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
Pi might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with 100 and
you were like okay that P looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 2112 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of100 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode this episode is sponsored by
kajabi and they've actually got
something really valuable for all of our
Deep dive listeners now if you haven't
heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online onine
Community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than $1,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to a $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
six billion dollars to creators that's
billion with a be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through product on the platform now back
in May 2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi
in real life kajabi Heroes Event in
Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I used
to grow my business from zero to over
$2.5 million per year from course
Revenue alone now people paid for the
pretty expensive tickets to watch this
keynote at the kajabi hero live event
but as an exclusive deal for deep dive
listeners kajabi have very kindly
offered to provide the recording of that
keynote completely for free to anyone
who listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that Keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode Dan Carter welcome to the
podcast thank you uh for inviting me
excited uh you know to to to talk to you
today it should be fun you've just
released this book Dan C the art of
winning 10 lessons in leadership purpose
and potential um and I've been going
through through and highlighting a bunch
of bits um which I'd love to talk to you
about and hopefully we can get some kind
of actionable thoughts or takeaways or
things that viewers and listeners can
think about as they're as they're
watching or listening to this episode
how does that sound oh that sounds great
and and it's a big part of the book um I
released an autobiography in 2015 after
I played my last game or last
International game uh for the All Blacks
and you know I've read a few
autobiographies and they're great and
really insightful about their career but
I wanted this not to be an autobiography
something
that that you can take lessons away from
whether you have a sporting background
whether you're in business or whether
you're just um you know just wanting to
to be the best you possibly can each and
every day I feel like there's something
in there for this book and it you know
challenge you to to to think about where
you're at in your life and and where you
want to go nice yeah one one thing I
really liked about this is that it's
organized thematically like purpose
resilience humility mindset pressure all
this kind of stuff and and then within
that you do a great job of like weaving
weaving in the stories but it's also not
just about rugby because I didn't really
know very much about rugby other than
just a very high level thing but there
it's so readable and relatable even as
someone who doesn't really follow rugby
and I was just like oh this is nice yeah
that's good like um you know because
because when I did finish playing uh
rugby professionally I I realized I
needed some help and I didn't want to
just talk to to rugby players that have
gone through the same experience that
I'd gone through and I talked to to
various uh former teammates of mine
about the approach process of navigating
change um as they transitioned out of
the sport of rugby and then also talked
to uh some footballers that uh went on
to have successful uh business careers
but also talked to a lot of uh
successful uh friends who'd been in in
business and CEO roles uh you know for
for you know big uh big companies and
you know when they finished their
careers were navigating changed there
was some learnings that that I got from
from them as well so it's uh you know
it's a very sort of General prob not
really a rugby book so if there are any
DieHard rugby fans uh listening to this
I apologize in advance it's not a whole
lot of rugby stories but there's some
incredible uh learnings to to help you
on your journey amazing so you start off
by talking about the idea of
repurposing and one of the things that
really struck me about this first
chapter is that you seem to have this
this fear of the word retirement and one
line that comes up again is like washed
up has been no good anymore I wonder how
why why is the first chapter called
repurposing because that's the stage of
my life I was in when writing this book
and and the foundation of this book
started um initially to to help me
through
this repurposing of my life I knew
exactly what I um what drove me every
morning I I got out of bed for close to
20 years so I played professional rugby
for 18 years and every morning I got out
of bed I wanted to be the best rugby
player I possibly could that's what was
driving my decision making uh almost
each and every day and then all of a
sudden to hang up the boots and and
finish playing I was a little bit lost
like who am I if I'm I'm not a rugby
player and uh like I just mentioned I
talked to a number of people and and
learned a lot from them uh there was one
person that I got put in touch with his
name was Kevin Roberts he's a former CEO
of advertising agency Sai and Sai and
and had worked with teams and and
individuals as they navigate change in
their life and when you have a really
clear purpose of of what you want to to
be in life and and then that changes you
need to go through this repurposing
process so I worked with
him uh for six months and I still use
him as a mentor uh today to help me but
we went through this this uh you know
this exercise of of repurposing and it
was probably the first time I really
looked inwardly uh for the first time
around who am I as a person you know
what a what are my you know
characteristics you know what what are
things
um uh that really represent uh who I am
you know whether that's around my work
ethic whether that's the importance of
family you whatever it is that came up
with a list of of those things and then
also you know what are some of some of
my beliefs you know things that have
helped me be the person that I am today
things that you know I really hold
myself accountable for I also looked at
things uh from my past um you know my
professional career what are the
learnings things that I that I loved and
want to use in this next chapter of my
life so all of a sudden I had some
framework because when I finished
playing rugby and I was you I was one of
the you know the four fortunate ones
that was able to have uh a long career
uh of playing professional sport for 18
years um you know I was financially
stable so I you know didn't need to to
rush into a job and I and I had I had
time on my hands um so I needed to to
work out what was going to drive me what
was that thing that that I'm missing um
every morning I get out of bed and to be
perfectly honest I'm still working
through that but I now have some
framework um to to help guide me so we
opportunities come my way I can say no
because it's not the path and the
direction that I'm I'm walking towards
and um and you know winning all things
winning and and Leadership is something
I'm I'm really uh really passionate
about nice yeah uh I'd love I'd love to
talk a little bit more about what is
your purpose and like how how you
thinking about that now but I wonder if
we can go back to during during the
rugby days um the sort of the first
lesson you have here in your sort of 10
lessons in leadership purpose and
potential is all about finding your
purpose and using that purpose to set
goals and to inform what you're doing
dayto day so I wonder
for how how how did you think about
purpose and goal setting when you were
doing when you were doing professional
rugby and then in a little bit we'll
talk about how you thinking about it now
yeah it's so hard it's not like you can
just click your fingers and go right
this is my purpose
I was lucky because I stumbled across
mine so as a 5-year-old
boy um watching the inaugural Rugby
World Cup
1987 um which was a Rugby World Cup that
was co-hosted by Australia and New
Zealand and I was 5 years old and and
watching the All Blacks play you know
with my father on TV and I still
remember there was a player called John
kin and he caught the ball and he ran
the length of the field beat 11 Italian
players which is the team that they're
playing against and scor this incredible
try I went straight out into the
backyard uh trying to implement uh John
K and I I wanted to to be just like him
so I continued watching the World Cup
there was another player Michael Jones
who was a really infu influential player
that played at that World Cup that I
wanted to Aspire to be I still remember
the captain of the final David Kirk
lifting the will and web Alis cup above
his head and something was ingrained in
me from that day that was my dream was
to to be like them and to be an all
black um I never thought it would
actually happen because I grew up in a
little country town of only 700 people
and I thought all blacks were supposed
to come from uh the big cities like
ockland Wellington and Christ Church but
that was that was a dream now that dream
became a reality in 2003 where I played
my first game for the old blacks uh
something I never thought would happen
but um but it did and I thought that I
could die the next day and die a happy
man because I've achieved everything uh
I want I dreamed of of achieving but I
couldn't be further from the truth like
when that game finished and I played my
first game and my dream became a reality
there was something within me that that
wasn't enough that that that wasn't my
purpose it was a dream um that I was
aspiring towards and a goal that i' I'd
now achieved but I wanted I wanted more
and as I walked off the field I was like
I don't want to be just another all
black that plays half a dozen games or
two or three seasons for the All Blacks
I want to be I want to be one of the all
black greats you know like John kwin
that I talked about and Michael Jones
but also my teenage years there was Jon
ALU Christian Cullen Andrew Merton I
want to strive to be an all black great
and and from that point on that that was
my purpose so I went into the changing
room I sat down I was like an all black
great what does that actually mean you
know it's quite a lofty thing it's
something you never actually achieve um
but what what is an all black great it
made me think so well in order to even
be in consideration for an all black
grade you need to have a a career in the
old blacks that spans over 10 years you
need to to work harder than all your
opposition and all your teammates
because there's going to be competition
for your
position so all of a sudden work ethic I
knew was going to be a really important
part of of my career I also knew that I
needed to grow and evolve because how I
play now as a 21 year old is going to be
very different in 10 years time if I'm
still playing um as a a 31y old so I
need to to constantly have a growth
mindset and and evolve as a person and
as a player so all sudden I I sort of
learned a little bit about uh purpose
and and what that looked like but then I
there was something missing and because
I couldn't just go on and focus on my
purpose each and every day yes it was
the thing that was driving me but I
needed structure and I needed to bring
that back to the the the now like what
does that look like um so I soon
realized that I needed to look at my
season as a whole
and set goals of things I wanted to
achieve through that season and in rugby
we have lots of different campaigns
maybe three or four different campaigns
throughout a season so there's no point
me focusing on the campaigns that were
at the end of the the season I need to
focus on the campaign that was directly
in front of me yeah um and in New
Zealand would' often play a provincial
uh competition uh called Super Rugby so
I'm not going to be able to be a great
all black if I don't play well at Super
Rugby level because I won't even be
selected for the old blacks so I would
reset goals for for that competition and
then I would break it down to to weeks
and then I break it down to days so
every Sunday I would plan my week and
I'd set goals for that week what I
wanted to achieve and then what I needed
to do each and every day on top of the
training and and work that we had as as
a player like what extra work do I need
to do Monday after training what extra
work do I need to do do at home whether
it's a stretching session some some
homework around the strategy of the game
a massage good nutrition plan all those
things so I knew exactly what I needed
to do every day so when I got to the
game I could just go out and play with
freedom because I've done the work so
it's one thing having a a really clear
purpose but then you need to bring it
back to the the structure of what does
that look like each and every day and if
you're continuing to to achieve those
things
um then you're moving in the right
direction and you're going to have bad
weeks you're going to have bad games
you're going to um you know Miss certain
parts of your preparation but at the
that Sunday became a really important
part of my week schedule where I would
review the week that had gone yeah what
went well what didn't go well and I'd
always write these things down and then
what do I need to do this week uh to to
be the best player I possibly can what
really struck me as I was reading this
chapter
was when when you break it down like
that it's it sounds really simple it's
like well you just figure out your
purpose and you break it down into goals
and then you just look at them every
week and you just figure out what you're
doing each day and I was just like damn
like almost no one does that oh yeah
actually a lot of people have you know
have either read the book and go oh my
God yeah that's that's a great idea to
actually sort of plan your week um but
before you plan your week you got to
work out like what direction are you are
you walking towards and that's probably
the most challenging thing of like
working
what it is that that you want to be and
Achieve um and I knew that I love rugby
so it's a passion one you got to
actually work out what you're good at
and and what you love doing and if you
have those things then you can start
moving in the right direction of what
you want to achieve you what is your uh
your purpose and in this part of of of
your life because it will change uh at
various stages of of your life and you
know I experienced that having finished
finished plane and it's a thing that you
need need to to spend time and and think
about and and once you have that the
power of of personal purpose is you know
is really
important you mentioned that initially
like for the throughout your childhood
the goal was to become an all black and
then you get there and then you're like
Ah that's not it it's to become an all
all black great and you mentioned that
the the goal of becoming an all black
you you sort of described it as being a
dream or a goal but not really a purpose
and so I guess how how do you see the
difference between purpose dream goal
Vision like it's somewhat semantic but
I'm really curious about like how you
break those things down yeah I think um
you know one thing that I've learned as
as a goal is something you can achieve
you know so I've become an all black
I've achieved it it's ticked whereas a
really Visionary purpose it's something
you strive towards but you never
actually achieve it's not like finished
my career I climbed up the mountain I
put a flag in and go yes I achieved my
purpose of being an all black great I
will never say that I'm an all black
great but if you're in the conversation
or other people are talking about it
then clearly you've done something right
in in your um you know in your in your
playing career so it's it's not actually
it doesn't have a a Finish Line is what
I'm trying to say and another one that
that we learned um as a team in the old
black we just won the Rugby World Cup in
2011 what's going to stop us from
subconsciously relaxing the year after
winning you know what is that it's like
purpose we need a really clear purpose
of it's not just about winning another
world cuper it's not just about being
number one team in the world at the
moment so we came up with this uh
purpose of being the most dominant team
in the history of world rugby and it's
quite a lofty uh purpose but it's
something once you all engage I like
well what does that look like and then
you break it down to what it looks like
and then the structure to to to walk
towards that and once again if we won
back-to-back World Cups we won again in
2015 does that make us the most dominant
team history of world rugby no not at
all we never actually achieve it yeah
but there's some people talking about
you know because we're the number one
team in the world for 9 years straight
you know almost a Whole Decade so people
are going actually that all black team
of 2010 to 2019 was you know actually
you know we were in the conversation
yeah so clearly we'd achieve something
through that uh that period where we had
a really clear purpose of of where we
wanted to to strive towards so that's
that's the kind of lofty vision of of a
purpose compared to a goal where it's
it's achievable and then you achieve
that and then you move on to the your
next goal or whatever it is so it sounds
like the purpose is almost the Direction
that's the an inspiring direction to
move towards and it's sort of the
Horizon is like you're never going to
reach it but like Yeah by virtue of
choosing that goal rather than that goal
for example it just sorry that purpose
rather than that purpose it changes the
way you approach your goals and then
your day-to-day life absolutely and
you'll see what you know um things that
you want to achieve uh along the journey
and and goals and you know your planning
and and
preparation uh as well to to help you
you know strive towards that
how important is enjoying the journey
it's it's it's hugely important
and and I got a you know a good
lesson you know in my teenage years
where you know I knew I wanted to be an
all black and you know as a 5-year-old
boy you're not thinking of it as a
career path because rugby wasn't even
professional back then it was it was
always a dream and then I'm starting to
make a few representative Rugby teams
and I'm starting okay maybe I'm actually
okay at this this rugby thing um you
know maybe I should pursue it a little
bit harder so I left my a little Country
School alsir College and and moved to a
really rich rugby history high school
called CH boys high when I was in a big
city it was my last year of high school
I got this is going to be the stepping
stone to me walking towards my goal of
being an all black this is this is going
to be a huge part of my career to to
keep on the you know the the New Zealand
Rugby scene because I'm now uh playing
you know for uh you know one of the best
uh rugby schools in in New Zealand so I
went to the croch boy high in the year
2000 I remember walking down the hallway
and I was looking around at all these
former All Blacks on the wall all these
trophies that they've won as a little
country boy I was it was all too much
for me and I like no no but this is this
is your dream to be an all black so I
was really serious I was like right I'm
just going to be the best rugby player I
possibly can it was driving me had one
of the worst seasons I've ever had and
the pressure was too much for me I
didn't enjoy it I was too focused on on
Rugby and and I finished high school and
there were a couple of senior rugby
clubs that wanted me to go play for them
I was like I've lost the love of the
game I I didn't enjoy my last season as
a rugby play it wasn't fun and I was
like I forgot why I play the game and
it's because I love it and enjoy it and
I wasn't enjoying uh the game of rugby
so what I did After High School is I
didn't play senior rugby I went and
played social rugby with uh my friends
and it was a uh it was a local uh under
21 competition and it was one of the
most fun seasons of ever head you know
at the stage where we're 18 19 years old
um you know a very social aspect of of
the sport so you know we're playing uh a
fun style of rugby we're having fun off
the field we're you know we're growing
as as teammates and people and
developing it was so much fun and I was
playing some really good rugby again and
that's what I was missing the year
before and because I found that love of
the game again and I was playing for the
right reasons not to try and be an all
black but to actually to to enjoy the
sport a lot more I naturally I started
playing some great rugby and then within
18 months um I was playing at a Rugby
World Cup uh for for the All Blacks It
All Happened really quickly after that
it was a huge learning of so through my
International career I always put a huge
focus on on enjoyment like why do you
what are you enjoying about the wig what
are some little elements that you can
bring bring some fun into your game
because that enjoyment and love for what
you're doing is is so
important that's really interesting that
you say that so so this was something I
was thinking as I was reading the book
because a lot of it especially that
first chapter on purpose is about like
figure out the goal set the thing and
you tell this fun story of when you were
like homeschooling your kids during the
pandemic I wonder like oh what was the
story there yeah that was a bit of a
shocker on on my behalf because I'm was
so so
you know obsessed with structure goal
setting being the best in the world um
and and then obviously the the global
pandemic I was forced um back to New
Zealand before they closed the
borders I was bouncing from Japan and
New Zealand through my the end of my
career and then all of a sudden I I
returned into you know pretty serious
lockdown with with my family had three
children and all of a sudden I was I was
homeschooling and you know my mindset is
if we're
homeschooling we're going to run the
best
homeschooling system in the world this
is what it's going to look like boys
you're going to get out of bed at this
time you're going to have breakfast at
this time you're going do mess at this
time you have a little break at this
time you're going to do some science
here you going do some reading here you
going do some writing break for lunch at
12:30 and I ran it like a
military and we got to the end of the
day my children were in tears they were
like this is awful like go away I was
the worst father in the world and my
wife just looked at me goes what the
hell are you doing like these are
children this is our home and I was like
I'm so sorry I just got so caught up in
in my Rugby structures and and I forgot
that you know that the children this is
home it's a challenging time and they
weren't having any fun any fun at all so
and so they that they weren't like
learning and didn't want to to be part
of of my military styled homeschooling
so it lasted one day and it was thrown
out the door yeah that so read that I
was just like wow so my book uh the one
that I'm I'm publishing in December is
called Feelgood productivity and the
whole thesis behind it is that actually
high performance productivity yes it's
about goal setting and stuff but
actually a huge part of it is about
making sure you're enjoying the process
because if you're enjoying it then
everything else just feels it's still
hard work but like there's some kind of
energy that you get from it it's like
there's something special you know more
creativity more productivity less stress
when you're when you're having fun yeah
absolutely and you need to that's why
when you're looking at diving into to
what your purpose is you need to know
that um it's what you love doing and and
you're good at it and if You' got those
two things then you're going to be
having fun along the way and when you
have setbacks and disappointments and um
you know you'll find elements because of
your your love for what you're doing um
that you will you'll get through those
moments and and and bounce back so that
enjoyment is is is hugely important so
I'm sure it'll be a fantastic book cuz
the importance of you know having fun
and enjoyment along the the journey is
yeah it's hugely important how do you
think about the balance between and I I
wonder if this is a balance but the
balance
between having fun but also like doing
the work when you don't feel like it cuz
I'm sure there were times where you had
to wake up at 500 to go to the gym and
you're like oh I don't really feel like
it this isn't really fun anymore I got
to drag myself out of bed or like a 10:
p.m. like swimming recovery session it's
like oh I just want to go to bed but
like or I just want to party like there
there is a a balance here right like how
do how do you think about that balance
absolutely and that's why it's really
important having a clear purpose
because you know it might be you've just
had a really tough game and your body's
absolutely battered and bruised and the
last thing you want to do is wake up on
a Sunday morning and and go jump in some
ice bass you know um but then okay well
what is your purpose are to be an all
black great what would an all black
great do in A Moment Like This would
he stay in bed and you know go watch a
movie or would he actually go and do the
work and that's why sort of one of my
values was you know do what's right when
no one's looking and I think that's a
really important value that um you are
doing these things behind the the scenes
um you know because your mind can play
some some some games on you and you know
you can take the shortcuts you can um
you know do things like not do your
recovery and no one will know but you um
but that's that's not high performance
that's not you know striving and walking
towards uh you know your your purpose
and and goals so it's just a nice to be
a reminder of um you know sort of what
is what is excellence and and you'll be
rewarded for that that hard work that
you do and that sacrifice that you do
when when no one's looking you'll be
rewarded at some stage nice um poetry
and plumbing what is poetry and plumbing
how does that relate to what we're
talking about oh it's it's a great
analogy that I learned from uh a very
successful entrepreneur Reed Hoffman uh
co-founder of of linkon and I was lucky
enough to to to interview him extremely
sort of nervous I got recently retired
from from rugby uh doing some work for
uh the Oxford University uh the Oxford
Foundry entrepreneurship school that
that set up and and helping uh Mentor
some of their Future Leaders um and I
got asked to to to interview Reed
Hoffman and he he talked about this
analogy uh poetry and and plumbing
plumbing and it sort of it made me think
and I wrote about it in the book but the
Poetry is is some to what we're talking
about that's your purpose that's the the
beautiful vision of what you want to
achieve and aspire to be towards but you
can't achieve that without the plumbing
the the the doing the action the
daytoday discipline and consistency of
doing uh the work so it's similar to
what I talked about is you know when I
walked off that field after my first
test match you know and I wanted to to
be an all black great that's the Poetry
that's that's the Beautiful thing that
I'm aspiring towards but then I had to
break it down to what does it look like
each year what does it look like each
week what does it look like each day so
I've got tangible things that that I'm
constantly doing um each and every day
to uh which is the the plumbing to to
strive towards uh you know walking
towards that that poetry so it was it
was a great analogy and he uses that in
the business sense um so here I'd use it
um in in sport and now I was learning
from one of the you know a fantastic
entrepreneur like like Reed is is you
know he used that analogy and uh in
business as well so you know for example
in in a team a business you you've got a
A team's purpose what you're all
striving towards for the the team to to
be successful and then you got um what
it is that every single person within
that team needs to do each day uh to
keep the wheels in motion uh to to keep
uh you know driving the the team forward
to towards that that beautiful piece of
poetry that uh you all striving towards
yeah yeah it's a really nice analogy
that that's what really struck me as I
was as I read it for the first time and
I was like oh this is such a nice way of
sort of laying out the the importance of
both aspects of it and I was thinking in
terms of you know when I was in medical
school I in in a way my my purpose at
that point was to be the best doctor I
can be uh but obviously anyone can have
goal of or the purpose of or the vision
or whatever of trying to be the best
doctor you can be but
fundamentally having I guess having the
Poetry without the plumbing it's just
like a pine in the sky idea it's just a
hallucination whereas what it actually
means is like well okay what does that
look like dayto day yeah you can't have
one without the other and that's a Bea
well you can but you know if you're just
you know I often see some people that
that don't have the Poetry this dream
this vision and they're just going
through the motions each each and every
day and you know they settle for
mediocrity and that's that's life um for
me that's not what's driving me I'm all
about uh you know high performance and
and wanting to to be the best version of
yourself you know that personal growth
you know how can I get better each and
every day so to to have um that analogy
of you know you can't have one uh
without the other is is a great way of
looking at it what is your or what did
SL what does your Sunday review process
look like how are you how are you going
about it so obviously it was it was much
easier when I was playing because you
know we were playing uh week in week out
so you had really sort of clear goals of
what you wanted to achieve each week and
then you had your training regime um of
okay training Monday Tuesday day off
Wednesday train Thursday Friday play
Saturday recovery day Sunday Etc so it
was very structured then all of a sudden
that structure's taken away from you
you're not not in the team environment
you're s you're here by yourself you got
your family you've got your your little
business interests you've got your
portfolio of Investments you've got your
your new guideline after repurposing of
framework of you know what you're you're
inspiring towards and and through that
you know I was like I'm just kind of
going through the motions a little bit
and I suddenly realized well you're not
actually doing you know your journaling
you on on your Sunday and planning your
week and
so I knew that one of my values was to
to earn my beer and and that's a saying
that I say like I get to the weekend the
end of the week and have I done what I
said I was going to do because if you
have you burnt yourself a beer so um so
well done so I needed to actually put
some things in place on a Sunday to to
make sure that I'm continuing to to grow
uh as a person and and do things that
I'd say I'd do so now that I don't have
rugby in my life I'm still sitting down
on a Sunday night and it's a lot more
General so I'll come up with a with a
phrase for the week you know which is a
bit like a
goal um you know and that's just
something that's I want to get to the
end of the week and going well have you
you lived what you said you're going to
live and then below that um I would
have um you know a couple of sort of one
liners you know make sure you you're
really present when you're at home with
the family uh be nice and keep SM in
this week um just really simple sort of
on liners to to kind of guide me back to
uh the phrase that driving me for that
week I also understand that uh for
me you know being a former uh athlete
that I the importance uh for for my
well-being is exercise I need I need to
exercise i' often set goals that I want
to achieve for the week whether it's
okay I need to do five Training sessions
this week and stipulate what they are
and and when they are um so I make sure
that I achieved that by the end of the
week I did what I said I was going to do
and then each day on the other side of
the page I write three things that I'm
grateful for just so have a a gr a
gratitude book which is right next to to
to my uh week plan of what I'm trying to
set out to do and just really simple
things you know like you know grateful
to have uh you know nutritional food for
the family and I to to weed grateful for
you know the sun shining today grateful
to be able to spend time with my
youngest son Cruz uh you know for the
morning whatever it is really often
repeat it's just nice way to bring me
sort of back down to earth and and focus
on you know things um you know things
that I have uh not that are not the
things that that I don't have and then
get to the end of the week I kind of
review the week did I do the things that
I said I was going to do did I do my
exercise I did I live um you
know uh the values that I I wrote out
and um and then did I ow my beer yes or
did I not okay well and and it's not all
perfect you know I have weeks that I I
you know don't write things in or I'm
traveling or whatever but I find when I
do have that structure uh it really sort
of helps me know that I'm I'm moving in
the right direction that's really cool
and and and do you do this in like a
physical journal or in some kind of app
or like I'm quite old school um so you
often see even at the end of my career
or the um yeah a lot of my younger
teammates were you know their iPads and
doing a digital version of their their
goals and and week planning where I'm
old school I need pen and paper as soon
as I put pen and paper it holds me
accountable like I'm writing it down and
if I'm writing it down I need to do this
because I get to the end of the week and
I review and if I've written it down and
I haven't done it you know I feel like
I've let myself down you know I'm either
getting lazy or I'm quite hard on myself
and there no better feeling than than
achieving and and doing things that you
set out uh to do even if it is uh you
know the most simple and basic things
and and with that uh breeds uh you know
consistency uh and discipline uh are two
things that uh that can go pretty easy
in your life you know you can be
motivated and do something really good
for a month and then it kind of dies off
um with this routine and this structure
is it really teaches me discipline last
I might be hung over or I might not want
to do this on a Sunday night but that
discipline of actually opening up my
book and writing it down it only takes
15 minutes but that discipline of doing
that is is really sort of beneficial and
and helps me and then the consistency uh
to do it um you know each week is is
another great thing to to have F this is
so good I I think I first came across
the idea of weekly doing a weekly review
in like 2015 when I read some
productivity book and I was like yeah
and I did it like three times and then
over the last like 8 years I've done it
maybe like 10 times in my life and I'm
like every time I do it I'm like oh it's
it's really helpful to do a weekly
review and to just think what are the
three things I want to achieve next week
and then I just forget I forget to look
at it something comes up and yeah oh so
easy it's so easy to be distracted and
you know I yeah I'm into a couple of uh
sort of younger athletes and there's a a
rugby league player that I caught up
with
recently in uh in Sydney and we just
called out for a coffee and he was going
through a bit of a you know tough spot
in terms of his form and things like
that and I just kind of asked him
because we've been you know talking for
about 18 months and you know was very
sort of disciplined and and I was like
was there anything you're not doing that
you're doing last year go he thought
about it go oh actually I kind of got a
bit slack on my you know my week
planning and journaling and and it was
just something so basic and so something
that just kind of dropped off you know
the busy you get um you know that's
probably one of the things that can can
drop Dr off pretty quickly and to be
honest it's quite hard for me with four
children to to have that time to to be
able to to do that and and like I said I
I have good weeks I have bad weeks you
know some weeks I won't write anything
and I'll kind of you know just not quite
H nail it and that's the first thing I
realize if I go back to that I have
structure I have discipline I have
consistency and and it helps me and sure
enough the the RO league players
mentoring he got back into it and he was
like thank you so much there was the
missing piece of the puzzle this year I
I just he used to take time each morning
where he just grab his coffee and just a
little bit of one-on-one time with
himself and and you know kind of jot
down his his thoughts and things that he
he he wanted to uh you wanted to achieve
for the week it was something so simple
but it's it can be something that drops
off uh pretty quickly yeah such a game
changer so then when when you do this
are you are you looking at it every day
as well to figure out like what did I
say in my weekly plan because um because
I've got the daily gratitude just you
know kind just flick across to the next
page and okay just just little constant
reminder but the big reviews more at the
end of the week on the Sunday where I
get a general feel for the uh General
feel for the week and whether it was a
successful one or or actually I need to
to work a bit harder the following week
and and that sets you up for the the
week ahead man this is so inspiring I'm
right I'm going to commit to this this
is just like gamechanging stuff um one
of the things you I think towards the
end of the book you have a phrase which
is that purpose is selfish wonder what
do you what do you mean by that ah yeah
purpose can be quite selfish because
it's something that you you know it's
very aspirational it's it's you know
it's personal purpose it's what um what
it means it means uh to you and what
what's striving you like I said um each
and every day I was getting out of bed
um and what does what does an all black
great do today you know he works hard
he's at the training field and you know
I was setting those goals and Things
Early in my career as uh you know in in
your early 20s and and then as life
evolves um you know you start to have
family you start to have
children and here I was on this this
journey of you know striving towards
greatness and you know I kind of had my
blinkers on at times where you know I
was forgetting uh about the importance
of you know family spending time with
them because I was so focused on on on
my Rugby and what I wanted to achieve in
in rugby so it can be a really a really
selfish things at at times where a lot
of the decision making is is about
yourself and what you want to achieve
but I think that's important
um you know that that you have that but
you find little pockets to be able to um
you know interact with with other things
that are really important to you uh as
well so it's not 24/7 you're focusing on
on Rugby and whatever that is is driving
you you know you need balance in your
life and I guess had times I didn't I
didn't have uh you know the best balance
and you're so you know you you've gotten
to know a lot of really high performers
you've interviewed them you've become
friends with them have you met anyone
who you feel has a good balance between
striving for high performance and also
having a very balanced and healthy sort
of personal life family life um it's
it's really hard to to engage um you
know you kind of meet someone and you
have assumptions that they're really
good um at life outside of what what
they're known for but unless you really
know them closely as a friend you know
you know a lot of people say okay well
Dan card is really successful with what
he achieved in rugby and life after
rugby and yeah he looks like a pretty
you know pretty good uh you know father
as well whereas something I learned was
I was so focused on Rugby that I thought
providing for my family was signing
you know lucrative contracts overseas
and playing in France and trying to win
competitions in Europe and then going to
Japan trying to win Japan competitions
and you know what part of that is you
know being a good father when you know
your children they just want you around
they don't really care so can you have
can you be the world's best father and
the world's you know best athlete you
know that's that's the what I was really
struggling with I wanted to but I felt
like I I couldn't and um you know often
I'd come home and i' had a bad game or
you didn't perform as well on the
training field as I would have liked I
was taking work home uh with me and you
know wasn't being as present as I should
have been at home so I was struggling to
to have that balance of adapting sort of
one to the other and you know there were
times where I actually just needed to
turn off my phone or just give myself a
little Pip talk before walking in the
door at home so okay just leave that
until tomorrow um and you know just be
present and and you know being the best
father isn't necessarily mean like stop
everything to to be a stay-at-home
father you know it's just more about
sort of engaging and being present so it
was a huge learning huge learning uh for
me and you know it's still something I
need to work uh you know hard on because
it's it's not easy by the way in case
you haven't heard the book that I've
been working on for the last 3 years is
now available for order it is called
Feelgood productivity and it's available
on Amazon and all other major retailers
and you can check out the website
Feelgood productivity.com for more
information and links to where you can
get yourself a copy yeah one one thing
that um my CEO coach does is he sets
alarms on his phone so like at 5:30 in
the morning he said his alarm goes off
and it says world's best athlete or
something so he's like right I'm in that
mode he goes to the gym and stuff and
then it's world's best coach because
that's his work and then at like 600
p.m. the alarm goes off and says world's
best father and husband and and just
seeing
that you know he says for him sort of
reminds him it's like okay on the
doorstep cool changing gears now forget
about work focus on presence and it
sounds like you found a strategy like
that similar I'm still I know the
importance of it I'm still struggling
with it a little bit and I love that
constant reminder that he's getting as
you can tell I love structure so I need
things uh in my life like uh like your
your coach has so um I might have to use
that tool to be honest that was great
have you have you any other strategies
that have been helpful in getting
getting the balance between performance
and like
family uh
I I
think you know so I was really focused
on Rugby and then the pandemic and I was
in the you know lockdown with children
where it was like one extreme to the
other and I was kind of struggling
because I'm kind of the the mentality of
I'm all in on one thing or another and I
was struggling to do little parts of of
things here and there so um I went to
The Other Extreme okay well I can't play
rugby now because there's no sport um
right I'm going to you know be really
engaged with the family sort of help out
do everything and then things started to
open up and then I went straight back to
to work okay I can travel now I can look
after my sponsors and I'm like oh and I
kind of was bouncing between one or one
or the other so it was just just sort of
constant reminders putting that week
planning was really important you know
so I know okay well Wednesday it's you I
don't have a lot of work on Wednesday so
I'm coaching my son's rugby team so you
know that's a great way to to connect
with him so just having little pockets
similar to to to to what your coach was
saying and just you know just nailing
each sort of moment that that you're in
and not drifting nice that's great stuff
um I wonder if we can turn to the idea
of pressure and one of the lines that
you say in the book is pressure is a
privilege what do you what do you mean
by that yeah it's it's something that
you know we had to change our mindset on
as a as a rugby team we loved dominating
teams and beating them by 30 or 40
points and we were good at doing that
we're the number one team in the world
2005 6 and seven going into Rugby World
Cup
and all of a sudden we were put under
excruciation amounts of pressure by a
French team in a quarterfinal and we
didn't want to be there and it was a
burden like as soon as the game got
tight and tough we we we didn't want to
be in those moments we wanted to be
beating teams uh quite
convincingly um so what we did
is what historically has happened in in
New Zealand Rugby history is the
Pinnacle of of rugby years as a Rugby
World Cup which comes around once every
four years and we won the noral Rugby
World Cup back in 1987 as I talked about
as a 5-year-old boy and then
often four years later you know probably
be you know the favorites to win the
next Rugby World Cup and then we
wouldn't win and then you know we'd be
favorites to win the next one we
wouldn't win and it gone on for 20 years
so what would happen is if the the All
Blacks didn't win a regular World Cup
the coaches would get fired and get a
new set of coaches in and they got a
4-year journey to win a Rugby World Cup
if they're unsuccessful they'd get fired
a new one and it went on for for 20 um
20 years it was incredible so we're
number one team in the world 2005 6 and
seven we went to the Rugby World Cup um
we lost uh in the quarterfinal to France
couldn't deal with the pressure um they
had a haric performance against us and
and won so what I thought would happen
is they get rid of the coaches and we
get a new set of coaches they come in
and you know we work towards the 2011
Rugby World Cup credit to New Zealand
Rugby they
reappointed the the coaches and they
said look you you need to
learn why you were the worst performing
all black side has Rugby World Cups we
knocked out in the quarterfinal and it
was a really bold move by the the Rugby
Union so they kept the the coaches
Graham Henry Wayne Smith and Steve
Hansen
and their job alongside the the
leadership team and um was to to learn
what went wrong what was it and we soon
realized that we were amazing athletes
at that World Cup great rugby players um
we were spending so much time in the gym
we were spending so much time on the on
the training field but we weren't
spending time on our mental strength and
that was the probably the thing that
that was missing so we had uh a head um
psychologists and Gilbert Anoka he went
and got some help uh with the forensic
psychologist K Evans and we started
to to to learn more about how our our
brain uh functions are under pressure um
but we needed to change our mindset
around pressure and we needed to to to
realize that oh actually and we soon
realized that the most successful people
in the
world live with pressure every
day so actually it's not a burden to
have pressure in your life it's a
privilege we're one of the privileged
view because every time we train and
play there's pressure whenever you play
for the old blacks there's so much
amount of pressure that um you know
you're expected to win every time you
you put on the black Jersey but we're
one of the lucky ones you know we we
live with pressure every day so we we
wanted to to walk towards pressure we
wanted to Embrace pressure we wanted to
have pressure every time we trained
because we knew in order to be
successful and Achieve greatness that we
needed to perform in those precious
situations so our mindset was actually
pressure is a privilege it's uh if you
got pressure there's two types of
pressure you know there's a homeless
person that has pressure trying to find
food every day or there's high
performance pressure whether that's in
business or sport um and we're focusing
on the high performance pressure and to
have that pressure in your life it's a
privilege you walk towards it you
embrace it you have the right tools to
be able to perform in those moments
that's when you start achieving your
goals that's start when you start um you
know doing things that you've you've set
out to do that's when you know you're on
the verge of of greatness so it's uh it
was amazing thing that we changed um so
after 2007 World Cup we spent a lot of
time around learning what our mind does
when it's under pressure um and we soon
came up with this analogy that kierans
uh taught us it's a bit around redhe
head and blue head so when you're under
pressure um often you go into a state of
redhead so you become distracted you're
off task you're not clear you're poor
communication you're not
decisive and you're distracted and
you're not performing in those moments
whereas on the flip side when you're in
a state of Blu head it's where you're
really calm you're decisive you're clear
great communication you're on task
you're living in the moment um and
that's where you wanted to to live the
majority of of your your time when
you're under
pressure and when you're in a state of
redhead you can do one of three things
you can freeze fight or flight and
everyone's different um in in those
situations so you needed to to look
learn what state do you go into when you
go into a state of redhe head freeze is
the state that I used to go in and as
the I played in the number 10 Jersey uh
for rugby and that's like the
quarterback you're making all the
decisions you're attacking strategy
you're communicating you're telling the
rest of the team uh the structure and
and the call for for what you're trying
to do so if I'm going to state of freeze
that means I go quiet I go Within Myself
and I'm become a really poor
Communicator so it's a really dangerous
position to be in uh there's freeze and
there's fight so you can go into a state
of fight and uh a lot of my teammates
were go to a state of fight so they're
off task they're under pressure they're
yelling at the referee they're yelling
at their teammates they're actually
physically trying to fight the
opposition they're of no value to the
team when they're in that redheaded
state of of fight or this flight you
just want to get out of there you know
so we all know sort of some teammates
that I've got a bit of an injury I I
don't want to be in this moment I'd
rather be on the sideline watching I I
don't so they just want to get the get
out of there they don't want to be in
that moment yeah so once you learn what
state you go into and we also learn
about what state our teammates go into
so you can help them get back into the
Blu head yeah so it's unrealistic that
you'll never go through a game of rugby
where you don't go into a state of
redhead but instead of staying in a
state of redhead for five minutes you're
running around because you're
you're angry about you know missing the
tackle or dropping the ball or a referee
decision you recognize that you're in
the state of redhead and you have tools
to get you back into the blue something
as simple as breathing recognizing that
you're in the red and getting you back
to the blue so everyone has uh different
tools and K Evans and gilber andoko were
helping players with finding tools one
of the tools that I had was slapping
myself on the league I'll drop a kick
I'll be running around going ah I can't
put oh sorry dropping the ball not
dropping a kick dropping the ball I'll
be running around go oh I let the team
down why did I drop the ball I have to
make up for it hold on that's not
helping the team thinking about what
just happened I slap myself on the leg
and I go right what do I need to do now
yeah okay catch the ball pass talk to
the number nine so it brings you back to
the here and now so you're really
present and you become really task
focused and once you become task focused
you're really clear and cisive and Cal
again so um you're back into a state of
bluehead
so once you have that education and that
learning you need to bring it into your
day-to-day life so all of a sudden after
2007 2008 9 10 and 11 our trainings were
so much more intense our coaches were
trying to manipulate us to get us into
the red as much as possible they would
get referees to come into training and
blatantly cheat so we start yelling at
him to get us distracted and it was all
just the tactic to trying to teach us
the tools to get back into the blue to
stay calm to SP to stay on task um or
else they might you know randomly send
guys off training so yellow card you're
off for no reason um they would make us
Sprint from one position to another so
the intensity of training was so much
harder the games became easy but we knew
that we we needed to live and embrace
and live in these these high pressure
situations so when it came to game time
we we were used to to dealing with it so
fast forward four years from 2007 when
we got knocked down the quarterfinal up
in the World Cup final haven't won a
World Cup in 24 years at home in New
Zealand against the French again and
they were putting in a heroic
performance and we were winning 87 on
the scoreboard it was so close they had
all the momentum and instead of
the players on the field you know been
in a state of freeze fight or flight
which happened in 2007 the guys loved
being in that environment they had great
eye contact great body language really
clear lines of communication they knew
in order to win a World Cup that they
had to be in in moments like this so
they embraced it and they absolutely
love been in that uh that situation
because we've been working so hard for
you know the last four years for that
moment and and we went on to to win that
World Cup first time in 24 years and a
lot of it was off the back of um having
the right tools to to deal with pressure
and spending time on our mental strength
and controlling controlling our mind it
was uh it was a huge learning I wish we
spent more time uh you know on the
psychology of controlling our mind
earlier in our our career because there
was some real real growth on in that and
you know we went on to Another World Cup
as well after that and a lot of it was
off the the back of that learning around
being able to perform Under
Pressure that's so good like I think a
lot of people when the conversation
turns to mindset or psychology they
start to be like oh this is all just
fluff like screw that like I guess
you've got a different a different view
of it well no initially it was very
similar to to that so when I started
playing in the early 2000s and we we
always had a psychology a psychologist
sorry
um as part of the team but if you were
spending time with a
psychologist um your teammates are
looking at you going M you're okay
you're a bit weird um you're not
supposed to be seeing him you're
supposed to just roll up your sleeves
and and just get on with it yeah
and um so he was doing work with the
team but not really doing any work on
one-on-one basis
so you wouldn't spend
time um with with the
psychologist um fast forward to the end
of my career if you weren't seen the
psychologist everyone's looking at you
going why why aren't you seeing him you
want to be the best rugby player you
want to be the best teammate here's an
incredible tool to help you be the best
um person best rugby player you possibly
can so the the difference between the
start and end of my career around you
know the the mindset of of using the
psychologist were completely different
and people go well you had a great
career if you could do anything
differently through your career what
would it be you I mly go look you know
the the disappointments you know the
learning it was just part of the journey
but if there was one thing I would have
loved to have used the psychologists
from from day one of my career it wasn't
until the back end of my career or the
second half of my career that I started
using him a lot more and that's where I
saw a lot more growth in in my game oh
wow so what sort of stuff like let's say
you're doing a one-onone session with a
psychologist what's happening in the
session that's helping an elite athlete
level up well you need to to to live in
the in the present so controlling your
mind to make sure you're not focusing on
things you can't control far too often
we spend too much time worrying about
the outcome um and we forget about the
process the process and the outcome will
take care of itself so it's a constant
reminder of what does your structure
look like and might be a really
important uh game this weekend that
means a lot more and all you're thinking
about like man I hope we don't lose or
we have to win
otherwise New Zealand's going to go to
to a minor state of depression if the
blacks don't want to World Cup and
that's actually something that happens
after uh Rugby World Cups if if we don't
win it's all sorts of pressure and all
of a sudden you're focusing on the
outcome so he is really good at bringing
you back to what do you need the process
like what do you need to do now and then
you'll go away from session like that
with really uh clear focus and every now
and then you'll find your mind drifting
um and you oh that's right I got to
bring back I've written down a plan of
like what I need to do each hour and I
bring back to the here and now so they
just remind you of what you're focusing
on they also um spend a lot of time
on having the right tools to control
your mind so a lot around the the red
head blue head um so spend a lot of time
of like
working uh what state you go into and
what you can do to bring you back into
the to the Blu head as well but often
it's just someone to talk to you know
about the the pressures of life I've
used them for you know stuff isn't going
well off the field just someone to kind
of know that they're there to help um
and and just going to to to talk to them
and um you know it was it was always uh
you know really energetic thing you walk
out of you know uh a coffee or a cup of
tea with a psychologist and you just
you're just talking and you walk out
like really energized okay right really
refocused and and really sort of excited
about uh you know what the rest of that
week looks
like there's a phrase I heard recently
which is that um if you ever hire a
coach the more expensive the coach gets
the less practical the advice becomes
and the more and the more about
psychology and about mindset and about
like emotions and all of that kind of
stuff it becomes cuz I'm sure like you
know
like yeah like you know a lot of the CEO
coaches I know who are being paid like
tens of thousands of dollars per hour
it's not really about business strategy
it's about controlling your mind
controlling your emotions and people
just get so much value out of that oh
that's that's the biggest um sort of
growth in in sport that that I've seen
so a lot of teams are they're training
pretty much the same in the gym or on
the training field it's it's that team
that that has the you know the culture
and also the the mindset to to to want
to be the best and if you're not on
every single game then even if you're
just two% off um mentally you can get
beaten by 30 points it is just that that
little you know subconsciously you
relaxed or you haven't prepared in the
right way or you don't have that mental
um that you did the previous week then
it's a really dangerous uh you know
place to be so having you know mental
skills coaches to to help make sure that
there is Edge in in your preparation
there's a real genuine preparation
that's going in as well you're not just
ticking boxes you're doing it for the
right reasons and yeah there's a lot of
growth that comes comes with you know
working with a you know mutal skills
coach What's the culture around talking
about feelings and emotions and stuff
cuz I imagine like group of lads the All
Blacks are sort of like you know all
these guys are absolutely jacked um the
whole like uh narratives around
masculinity and stuff tends to underplay
talking about feelings talking about
emotions is that something that that you
guys have done with it's something
that's evolved um the importance of you
know the players uh well-being
is you know it's a priority and uh in a
team like the All Blacks and you know
once again like when I first started
it's something you don't you don't show
your emotions you know you just kind of
like I said you roll your sleeves up and
just get on with it um you know it's the
masculine thing to do Rugby's a
masculine sport you go out there you go
to war you bash each other and then you
have a a beer afterwards and it's a it's
a bloody good week mate and um whereas
now I've seen you know play
driven um you know sort of Wellness
groups where you know they sit down
around a bowl of Cava I'm not sure if
you know what Cava is it's like a
champagne type thing no no Cava is like
a um you get it a lot in the Pacific
Islands Fiji
songa um it's a it's a root vegetable
that's ground down and it tastes and
looks like muddy water you kind of sit
down it's a traditional thing that the
Pacific Islanders uh do and you just
you're just kind of sitting around and
you're just playing the guitar and you
just actually end up you know talking
about about anything um and you know
sort of spending spending a lot more
time um yeah just just talking a lot
more openly uh than we used to and I
think the younger generation the
Millennials in the in the team in
particular they're they're a lot more
sort of open and sensitive to to to
those kind of conversations where sort
of my era is something that you just
you'd never do you know you never ask a
mate how you feeling because you know
the answer would be you're good and
that's the end of the conversation we
got it's a lot more open and and also as
a Management Group you know spending
much more time on working on the
individual so another value that we had
in the All Blacks was um better people
make better All Blacks um so far too
often in the history we'd focus on um
trying to be the best the product is the
rugby player you know there's no sort of
human element we just want you to be the
best rugby player but we soon realize
actually if we work out who you are um
the person if we can better you as a
person you know help you connect with
your family help you be a better citizen
um make you feel like you've got a real
sense of belonging in this environment
we care about your family we understand
how many children you have who you're
married to to what village you grow up
in what um what culture you come from
and we celebrate
that then that's an environment where
we're helping you as a person and if
we're helping you as a person the end
result is you being a bit all black yeah
you know because you've got the sense of
belonging you're like a family you want
to you want to repay the the management
the coaches your teammates that really
care about you as a person well actually
you know that helps me feel a lot more
comfortable I'm going to go out there
and be be this be the best rubby player
I possibly can so better people make
better roblx or something that we live
by just on the note so so you mentioned
family one one thing that we're
struggling with in in our team in the
business and I know a lot of people
struggle with this as well is the
balance between hey we're one big happy
family where we're all out looking out
for each other and no one ever gets
fired versus we're a team where you're
always kind of competing for your place
on the team because you know that if
you're underperforming someone else's
like you're laying the team down how do
you guys think about the balance between
the family Vibes and the this is a high
performance sports team yeah it's it's
really it's it's a great question
because some of the meetings that I've
been in um were leadership
meetings um meetings with the leadership
group and coaches have been
quite quite challenging in terms
of huge debates you know um because as
new zealanders we at times avoid
conflict we just want everything to be
happy families everything's great this
is good but in order to to have growth I
think you need to have hard
conversations um you need to to push
your case and debate
things um you need to be challenging the
way we're doing things constantly
looking to evolve if you don't believe
in in in an idea or game plan you need
to to lay down your debate you know why
give an alternative um have really be
vulnerable and have really uh open
conversations so we used to have this
thing in the All Blacks um when you
needed to have one of those
conversations the difficult ones that we
often shy away from um it's called
entering the danger so I'd
say um can I can I enter the danger with
you so therefore you knew straight away
that it was nothing personal
I'm not having this because I don't like
you I'm having this because I so much
about this team and I want us to
together to be successful and the
greatest rugby team in in the world so
come into the danger hey I don't like
the way you did this or hey I think you
know we could look at a different way of
of doing this so I'd have one of those
uncomfortable conversations with you so
we entered the danger and we would
debate um things but the key at the end
of that that meeting or that
conversation is
whether you agreed or not you need to
commit to one and then be aligned and
walk out of that together yeah because
the dangers of um not agreeing and
they're committing to one and it wasn't
your idea that you go away to your
little subgroup and go oh mate this is
what we're doing but don't you wish we
were doing this and it could be like
like a disease really infectious and and
not uh helpful of of the team team
culture so the importance of you know
high performance making sure that all
the decisions that you make is what's
best for the team and know that that's
not what's the decision is not what best
for the individual really helps grow
that uh that high performing team team
culture so I don't take it personally if
if you don't like what I say or agree
with what I I say um but you're prepared
to to challenge me on that because you
think that that's what's best for the
for the team so that real team first
mentality helps helps nurture and and
grow those those difficult conversations
that often we we uh we shy away from and
often we found we were when we were
having those
those difficult challenging
conversations is when we were getting
growth whereas if we weren't performing
that well and it's often because we were
shying away from
um from those those difficult
conversations and we were kind of
bullshitting ourselves oh you know
everything's fine everything's good
it'll be okay I will sort out later
whatever it was and I would come back to
to bite you in the
ass so changing gears a bit so you've
you've had you know a highly illustrious
career you've had your face slapped on
newspapers and magazines and like
International Rocky Player of the Year
and all that kind of stuff how have you
ever struggled with humility and staying
GR rounded in the light of all of the
success uh absolutely yeah it's it's a
huge value of mine and and also the All
Blacks is to just to remind yourself who
you are and where you come from and
through all the success and
accolades um you know you can be
challenged on not getting too far ahead
of yourself so it's really important for
me to have a really close group of
friends and family that would uh you
know
call um call me out when I was getting a
little bit ahead of myself and thought I
was a bit better than I actually was
after every good game I'd have for the
All Blacks the the all black New Zealand
Rugby CEO would often find me at the the
afterm match function and he' always
just kicked me on my feet he just K
kicked my shoes first time he did I was
like what are you doing go I'm just
making sure your feet are still on the
ground and it was just a little Conant
reminder just you know great game um but
just don't get ahead of yourself you
know just continue to to remember you
wouldn't be able to do that without your
teammates and and you know the the hard
work doesn't stop now but you know
there's been occasions where I made you
know poor
decisions um just got a got a little bit
of hit of myself thought I was a little
bit better than than I than I was and
this this world's got a beautiful way of
sort of bringing you bringing you back
down to earth uh when you make poor
decisions or or you think that you are
better than you you actually are so it's
uh yeah it's a really important uh
important value of you know humility and
you know surrounding yourself with the
right people that you know often when I
go and have a drink with um you know my
high school friends or primary school
friends that knew me before I play rugby
I might have a fantastic game might kick
90% kick nine goals out of 10 I can
assure you my close mates are telling me
about the one I missed not the nine that
I got um whereas you know people that
you know want to be with you because of
what you've achieved they'll only give
you accolades uh about the nine kicks
that you got and how great you are and
you know that's that's not
helpful yeah um one of the chapters is
about um resilience and dealing with
setbacks you've had a bunch of setbacks
in your career with like injuries and
things like that and I know that you
know anyone listening to this or
watching this will have also experienced
major or minor setbacks in their life
where they've maybe had a goal or a
vision or a purpose to work towards and
then the universe has dropped a piano on
them and like something is something bad
has
happened in I guess in your world you
know the the world of of of elite high
performance what are some strategies
that you and your team have found
helpful for dealing with dealing with
setbacks yeah it's it's hugely important
particularly in in today's you know
today's world you need to understand we
don't live in a a a perfect world
there's going to going to be
disappointments there's going to be
setbacks you're not going to achieve
every single goal you set out to achieve
but having the right tools to to deal
with those situations can be a huge
Advantage give you so much motivation
give you real strength and desire to um
you to to learn from those learn from
those moments so a lot of people look at
my career and just focus on the success
but I firmly believe the person that I
am today it's not because of the
trophies that I've won or the the
accolades that I get it's it's because
of the the difficult times the
setbacks that I've had and that you know
the things that not many people sort of
know or or learn about and that's what I
you know wanted to to share and the
chapter and my book around resilience
and having the right tools to deal with
resilience so there
amazing um you know story that that I
tell that I used to hate to talk about
because it was at the 2011 Rugby World
Cup where we went on to win it um and
I'd been the vice captain of the team
for three years behind the great Richie
mcco but I'd never Captain the All
Blacks um whenever he wouldn't play I
wouldn't play for whatever reason but in
the last round robin game of the Rugby
World Cup in New Zealand I got the phone
call the day before the game The Last R
Robin game to Captain the All Blacks one
of the best uh phone calls that that
I've had and of course I said yes Richie
mcco pulled out late with a little
niggling injury and here I was really
proud moment uh to to Captain the All
Blacks for the first time so I went off
to the the press conference day before
the game uh to talk to the media about
how proud I was to finally Captain the
All Blacks what a special moment it was
for my family and I went off to our
final training run uh which is called
the captain's run which as the captain
gets to decide what you do is quite a
proud moment this is feeling good it's
been a great day for me uh we went
through the captain's run I always
finished the captain's run with a few
shots a goal um and I've been kicking
goals ever since I could walk dad taught
me to kick with both feet as soon as I
could walks I've kicked millions of
kicks in my life my last shot at goal I
was lining up the kick and as I came in
Kick and the impact of the my boot
hitting the ball I dropped to the ground
and I had a serious injury and my groin
had just
um it actually torn off my pubic bone
and I just fell to the ground in extreme
Agony and this is my third world cup and
I'd had two fa World Cups we' done so
much work around the psychology we I
just felt like we were destined to
finally win a World Cup I was 28 I was
in the prime of my career everything was
going so well I thought this is my time
this is my moment and and then for it to
all be taken away by such a serious
injury I was I was devast stated so I
rushed off to
the uh the the Medical Center where I
had scans um so I was with my my doctor
and and then the specialist my doctor
like do you want to see the results and
I was like no I knew in my mind that my
dream was over this is and I'm a firm
believer that things happen for a reason
but this was going to be my last World
cut and all those thoughts of why me why
now why such a serious injury nothing
made sense in my mind at all everything
had just been taken away from me I
jumped in the car to go back to the
hotel um and halfway on the Journey Back
to the Hotel I hey Doc you know is my
world cup dream over and she's like yes
and I just burst into tears I cried all
the way back to the hotel went to my
room you know players would come through
coaches would come through to but they
couldn't say anything there's nothing
that they could say could change this
and it was just like dead silence every
time uh someone came in you know it was
it was nice to know that they were
thinking of me and make the effort to
come and and that helped but I was
distraught so I was I was angry I was
sad I was you disappointed at all the
emotions you know running through my
body and um but then you know after a
couple of days I was like well hold on
like you know what does an all black
great do in situations like this so my
purpose really helped me through uh
through this the setback what an nor
black great do that's right all black
great rehabs this injury better than
anyone's rehabed this injury before an
all black great um resets goals you know
you said that an all black great needs
to play for 10 years or longer so I
signed a new contract to play for
another four years in New Zealand um to
get me through to another world cup um
and also an all black great puts the
team first so what does the team need me
to do now well I'm injured so I need to
help the player plan in my position he
went on to get injured as well so they
brought in another player so I had to
help him he got injured he went to a
four string number 10 and it's a great
story CU um the fourth string number 10
went on to kick the winning goal in the
World Cup final
but through that process there was some
great tools and learnings to help me
deal with resilience the first one was
the importance to to grief so far too
often I see people have a really setback
dis appointment and they just they move
on really positive God it's not that
important not it's not that important H
actually right no no really positive
mindset straight away and I've seen that
it you know bites them in the ass
further down the track CU they don't
deal with your emotions straight away so
it's important to grieve deal with your
emotions so much so that when I have an
injury my wife knows to stay away from
me for 24 hours cuz I'm not a nice
person to be around I'm grumpy I'm angry
I'm just dealing processing at all but
there needs to be you need to flick the
switch at some stage so for me it was 24
hours and with depending on the the
severity of the sitb back it can be a
little bit longer but there's no point
me moping around the hotel room for the
next two weeks feeling sorry for myself
so I do that for 24 hours I flick the
switch that's when I change my mindset
into a positive one okay what are the
the goals that I want to to sit now that
I've injured whether it's your rehab or
longer term of uh years time so I reset
my goals so that's another really
important thing of of dealing dealing
with a
setback um so it's that's really helped
me and I had this new motivation to to
bounce back uh from from this injury
yeah uh 2012 I got named 12 months later
you know World rugby player of the year
so I I returned and had a fantastic year
2015 Rugby World Cup was one of my sort
of best uh Rugby World Cups that over
played you know sort of man of the match
performance the Rugby World Cup final I
was able to bounce back all of a
sudden four years earlier
when things weren't making any sense
they all made sense now um all those
moments and setbacks were built up to
make me a stronger more motivated um
player and in 2015 so I kind of sit
across from you today knowing that uh
you know the person that I am today a
lot more sort of resilient and have the
tools to help deal with with resilience
is is uh because of of those setbacks
that that I had through my career love
it um we got a couple of minutes left
before you have to go I wonder if we can
flick to the back of the book and talk
through some of the exercises that you
recommend people people go over um so
I'm just going to read some of these and
then I just love your D to just Riff on
these sort of like why why we've added
these exercises in absolutely um so um
question number one what are what are
the three positive words that best
describe you and what are the three
positive words you would like people to
say about you when describing your
character that's interesting question
like what's the rationale behind that
yeah I think
um it's nice to think about sort of
positive and and the direction that
you're you're wanting to go it's like
it's an aspirational thing yeah um and
it's determined by someone else it's not
you saying um I'm caring I'm kind I'm
hardworking it's words that people you
want people to say of you because
similar to your purpose you know if
you're in that conversation of those
things um the people are saying about
you it's clearly that's um what what
you're portraying so it's just it's a
thing to to kind of challenge you a
little bit about um the type of person
that that you you want to be seen as
nice um question four where do you want
to be in five years and in one year so I
guess the question there is so you've
got your purpose which is to be an all
all black
great and then are you thinking about
like what does the 5-year version of
this look like what does the one-year
version look like yeah I mean and and it
depends sort of what stage you uh people
are in in in their career um but like
we've talked about your your purpose
isn't something that you can achieve in
one year or five years so you need to to
kind of set goals and and targets and
and that's why having those two sort of
onee and fiveyear targets of you know
kind of where you want to be that's in
line with with your purpose uh so they
kind of goals that you you're striving
towards um that that you're wanting to
achieve that's aligned with with your
purpose nice question eight what is your
one word Equity what is the one word
Equity yes that's an interesting one and
I talk about it uh sort of in detail in
in the book but it's it's like um it's
almost like a I don't want to say a
spirit animal but you know it's like
what is the the one
thing that that really defines you you
know your character you know for example
my my wife's uh one word Equity is is
nurturer like she just nurtures our
family the children she's constantly
wanting to to to look after and care and
grow uh the people around here uh my one
word Equity is Ambassador and when you
think of Ambassador it's you think okay
Ambassador for a lot of uh you know
companies and sponsorship deals but no
like I'm an
ambassador uh for New Zealand you know
like I I'm really proud about where I
come from an ambassador for what I think
is the best sport in the world rugby I'm
an ambassador for uh you know for for
family I'm an ambassador for um various
things and that's just some oh
Ambassador for for for winning um so
yeah that's uh that's your one word
Equity just one word that
can in a way sort of Define uh who you
are and I guess it's season specific
because I guess you weren't always your
one word wasn't always Ambassador no
definitely not it's it's where I'm out
sort of right now like as a rugby player
I wasn't uh my one R Equity wasn't an
ambassador and it's something you know
every couple of years you want you want
to go back and uh so those questions at
the back of the book uh where you're at
right now and I would Cheng people to
open up the book in another two years or
3 years and see whether those things are
still relevant because your journey will
will change and evolve and and those
question the answers to those questions
will will evolve and and change over
time as well and then final question one
thing that you've alluded to a few times
in our conversation you said one of my
core values is dot do dot um any tips
how does like if someone's reached end
of this episode you they've been
listening to us for the last Almost 2
hours how might they go about figuring
out what what their core values are just
writing things down um that you want to
live by you know for me uh value could
be work conquers all I know it's it's a
really sort of General thing and there's
a lot of things that that help you you
conquer things but work ethic is a
really important value for me so it's
just a constant reminder that I need to
be put in uh putting in the work so just
writing you know start with a list of
whether it's six values that you want to
live by so basically you can get to the
end of the week Y and you got your your
core values uh whether it's 6 8 two
whatever it is um you know do I live by
those today you know health is wealth
you know could be another one so did I
make good choices around sort of my
health uh Health this week and did I eat
well did I do my exercise whatever it is
no I didn't okay well you know is this
something something that's important to
me in my life yes well then why aren't
you living uh you know those values just
having a a list of of your core values
that that you live by each and every day
sick Dan mate this been absolutely
fantastic um I I've got some homework
from this episode so this weekend going
to do the exercises in the back so I'm
committing to this on on air and I'll
share them with our telegram Community
if anyone's interested in free link down
below to our telegram Community going to
start doing the weekly review um and I'm
going to figure out what is the poetry
version of my purpose cuz I feel like
I'm doing a lot of Plumbing right now
without a lot of poetry and so just
getting that mindset shift I think will
be super helpful any final words of
wisdom for anyone who's who's who's
still with us no thank you um obviously
thank you for listening the fact that
we're end of the the podcast and for
those people that have made it all the
way to the end I appreciate uh uh you
listening and these aren't these
learnings aren't you know like SE in
stone it's not like you have to do this
this this and this in order to to win
and be successful these are just some of
the learnings that I've learned through
my career um and hopefully there's
something in there in the book The Art
of winning that can really resonate with
you and help you be the best version of
yourself and and really help with uh you
know that that personal growth that
they're all uh striving towards
brilliant Dan thank you so much and guys
if you are listening or watching to this
this is a sick book The Art of winning
we'll put a link down in the video
description of the show notes you can
see I've got little tags got the little
highlights if you happen to be watching
this on YouTube and yeah I'm going to be
annotating the hell out of it in terms
of the sort of final questions at the
end where I'm like cool I'm carve out a
few hours to really think about this
because I really think this is this is
what I'm missing in terms of like yeah
figuring out these big questions of
Direction kind thank you so much for the
the support of the book it's it's been a
great process over the last couple of
years writing it had a huge amount of
support from the Publishers um also The
Ghost Writer Steve did a fantastic job
of getting my tone of voice and just to
see you know the it's only been out in
the bookshelves for a couple of months
but just to see some of the the reviews
some of the comments that um the the
readers are writing jeez I'm getting
people that are resigning from their job
um after reading it because you know
they they realize they're not getting
that fulfillment or or purpose and and
what they currently have in their life
and and they taking control of their
life and and and moving forward
um with with this new motivation um so
um you be nothing but sort of supportive
of the book I really appreciate that no
thank you very much for coming on thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions
questions or any insights or any
thoughts about the episode that would be
awesome and if you enjoyed this episode
you might like to check out this episode
here as well which links in with some of
the stuff that we talked about in the
episode so thanks for watching uh do hit
the Subscribe button if you aren't
already and I'll see you next time
bye-bye